just over the Benjamin Franklin Bridge I
love Philly it's a very good city to
live in you're surrounded by history yep
I never noticed it it's perhaps not that
surprising that Stephen Starr hasn't had
time to take in Philly's historic sights
he has 19 restaurants in this town alone
the left has a rich history like New
York of immigrants yeah and it was those
people that brought a lot of the culture
and and food to this city star operates
a total of 35 restaurants around the
world from a traditional English pub to
his famed temple of Asian fusion this
restaurant has been here for 21 years
yes it was our second restaurant that we
ever opened Budokan which opened here in
1998 features a 12-foot golden statue
and crowd favorites including edamame
dumplings an Asian Caesar salad and tuna
tartare spring rolls I mean it still
feels incredibly fresh but do you feel
like you have to go back and sort of
recalibrate every couple of years yeah I
do it's a balance you have to come up
with a staying fresh but not
disappointing people that have their
classic base stars Empire is well
established at this point but when he
first went into the business he had
almost no experience but what I always
had I was like an A&R guy at a record
company
I recognized talent they just I knew it
inside it just was something I felt I
knew when something would be popular
with my guests I know it I could smell
it I could taste it early on his
passions were music and comedy starting
at 20 he opened a series of comedy and
music clubs attracting acts that would
dominate popular culture what from that
world do you carry with you today what I
learned was the show right I promote it
I produce shows so whether they be Joni
Mitchell with an acoustic guitar and a
dulcimer or kiss with makeup and things
exploding all of it was the show his
first foray into food
the Continental restaurants and martini
bar 1995 I open this and I had just sold
my concert business a couple years
before I really didn't know what to do
and then a movie called swingers came
out I was fortunate as I opened the
Continental martini thing and then
swingers came out and then everyone
wanted to drink martinis and everyone
wanted to be Vince Vaughn
he's like Sodom and Gomorrah here people
were passing out every night
young girls heads on the table but
because they didn't know how to drink
them to the point one night I said I'm
selling it I can't I can't do this I
feel I felt like I was like bringing
crack to America but star eventually
found his way by 2001 he was in the big
leagues bringing Japan's iron chef
Masaharu Morimoto to the US five years
later the former club owner took his act
to Broadway the Big Apple as much as you
have hometown pride you've also said you
really wanted to make it big in New York
and then it mattered why is that I
wanted to make it big in New York
because that's the standard right that
everyone has for making it big you know
I would go to the James Beard Awards and
I was nominated but it was always like
you know and Danny Meyer John Jorge
Mario Batali Stephen Starr and what's
that about what was like cuz I was like
the Philly guy and no one really knew
who I was you know I wasn't on the minds
of everyone I just was the guy that 90
miles away
there are now six Stephen Starr ventures
in New York including the acclaimed
classic French restaurant Lou cuckoo and
a hugely popular California Italian
upland so you've said in interviews that
your motto is trust no one that you are
a glass half empty kind of guy yes this
pessimism breed greatness yes it does in
this way if you look at life that way
you'll never be disappointed I used to
say the glass is half empty and it's
probably poisoned
and the beard award goes to Stephen star
pessimism sometimes pays off in May star
finally took home the James Beard Award
for best restaurateur that wasn't your
first time being nominated for a
restaurant no I was nominated I think
six times for James Beard everyone told
me I was gonna win it last year right I
mean Thomas Keller came over to me and
said sure you're a kid so I figure
though if he said it God talks to him
great I'm great
he knows and then I didn't win it then
either so I figured eventually are you
upset yes yes were you angry I didn't
show it but I was mad I couldn't bear to
hear my daughter Sarah say you're still
number one to me Dad I couldn't hear
that another year but success doesn't
necessarily mean that star is content
I'm embarrassed to actually say that the
opening night is the saddest night for
me right that I everyone's there they're
all dressed up they're having fun
drinking drinks and shaking my hand and
I want to just go home and watch CNN or
CBS I should say yeah I just want to get
away from everybody on opening night
there's a sadness there even after more
than 20 years in the business he still
can't shake the high of opening a new
restaurant we're still in the semi ugly
phase yeah right but once it really
starts to take shape it's the most my
adrenaline gets pumping his neighborhood
spot the love is scheduled to open in
Philadelphia this fall so is that a nod
to the City of Brotherly Love when is
the love about to me it's a nod to Barry
White but Amy Alexi was my partner in
this
it was her idea this name I think it's
about the love the love of the food the
product all these things it's a little
strange the name right but yeah the more
you say it the more I want to say it I
want to say the love are we going
tonight
love where is the love right here where
is the love right here